hey Zack what was the hardest action
sequence to film during and be making of
Man of Steel the hardest thing to shoot
was the Zod Superman fight only because
it was constructed from so many small
pieces and these guys were basically on
green-screen kind of grappling with each
other some of the time sometimes on a
wire sometimes on a box is very abstract
in the filming because you're basically
dealing with like a puzzle game where
you're just imagining that the pieces
are gonna fit together yeah just one
move at a time you know it's always like
one move at a time
one punch okay it's interesting because
we shot the jor-el Zod fight yeah that
was different and they're just fighting
each other for real and in the other
scene there in the real outfits but
everything else got to be put in later
it's like this weird inversion in first
version of the fight and and that one
you guys could kind of fight through a
bunch of it and then the other one you
could only one thing at a time maybe
strange no I liked working on that fight
with Russell and you know Russell's a
good fighter he's had some history with
it yeah he's done some of that fighting
but yeah I love shooting the ending I
love the movie even though I was scream
screen all that I just I know it would
look pretty dope pretty girl in it yeah
pretty fun